hi everyone i'm jonathan trance and
today I have a very nice tactical
challenge I'm really proud of this one I
hope you guys enjoy it so when you see
the puzzle on your screen go ahead pause
your video and we'll see if you can
solve it in this position it's white to
move so once again go ahead and pause
your video if you do need more time go
ahead and take it try to see as deep as
you can in this position and see if you
can work it all the way out to its
conclusion in this position it's obvious
that white has a lot of attacking
chances against the black King both of
the bishops are pointed towards the King
we have the G file with which to work
and in this position the move that it
might be tempting but is not correct is
Bishop to h6 this does in fact wait in
exchange after g6 in after you trade on
f8 you did win in exchange but flag has
good compensation in the form of two of
bishops and the bishop will go to g7 and
it'll be a powerful attacking piece
against the White King you can do better
so if you didn't you know if you thought
Bishop h6 was the move go ahead pause
your video again because here comes in
the solution the right move in this
position is rook takes g7 now blacks
move is semi forced there's no reason
not to take the rook and again go ahead
and see if you can find the right move
here there's a couple tempting options
one thing you might be tempted to do is
play rook to g1 check but after King to
h8 you don't really have a meaningful
way to make anymore process progress on
this attack here so going back the right
move here let's dish up to h6 check
the king should go to the corner it's
quite deadly to go onto the G file and
now what is the best move here for white
go ahead again you may want to pause
your video in this position white can
play Bishop to g7 check so he's forcing
the black King to come out after the
King takes Queen to g5 check blacks move
is forced in now Queen to f6 and once
again the black King goes to the G file
so hopefully this move is obvious enough
rook to g1 and now Bishop to g3 so once
more it's worth pausing your video and
trying to solve this position so I'll
give you a couple seconds here before I
reveal the solution it's obviously very
tempting to take on g3 with the rook
which forces black to give up his queen
but after either recapture on g3 lek
does have two rooks for the Queen and
your attack is is gone so much better in
this position and again go ahead pause
your video if you haven't found it yet
this is a really nice move the winning
move here for white is f4 now you're
just threatening to take on g3 and if
the Queen takes on f4 you can trade
Queens and do to the pin on the G file
white just want to Queen if for example
in this position black tries to play
rook F to d8 again there's only one move
here for white
tempting is the take on g3 but this is
incorrect
after king to f8 suppose White's decides
I'll play Bishop to h7 threatening made
on g8 well the king just runs away and
there's absolutely nothing after Rick g8
King D 7
even if Queen takes f7 king c6 and black
runs away and he's up material so going
back in this position once more go ahead
and pause your video if you need some
extra time but the solution is Queen to
h6 we needed to prevent the King from
running to f8 so Queen to h6 and now
black is absolutely powerless against
the threats on h7 and the threat on g3
so why should go on to win in the next
few moves here thank you everybody for
watching this tactical challenge if you
liked this you want to see more great
chess content just like this hit like
share subscribe and we'll see you next
week for another tactical challenge